[Music]
an historic newspaper in Jeopardy the
student-run paper at UNLV could
Disappear by next year but as Ryan
Matthey shows us it could be saved but
the student body would pay the cost
for nearly seven decades students at
UNLV have depended on this student
newspaper for their student news but
pretty soon it could all be thrown away
forced to go to a digital only platform
or dissolve altogether what could save
them students here and their wallets so
let me hit
save and close definitely for sports
we're going to have here like the Canon
the scarlet and gray Free Press as
editor-in-chief Vanessa Booth says
funding has always been a woe then more
woes this past January they would like
to see more buy-in from the university
community that you know they don't want
to be the sole providers for us the Las
Vegas Review Journal who once printed
their papers for free on top of funding
pulled out this January and other
funding they compete against other
student organizations for that amount
alone not enough to maintain a full
staff fix broken printers upkeep and
online presence and frankly stay alive
if he doesn't pass I can't say
definitively that there will be a
student newspaper and it's like 70 years
worth of student news it's a little
scary to think about this is the history
right here at the University but a
permanent solution is on the horizon
this is how we kind of keep it if the
Nevada system of higher education
approves of it the Board of Regents meet
Friday to discuss a fee over 30 000
students would bear the burden of a
proposed increase of 20 cents per unit
per student for undergraduates that's
roughly three dollars or less per
semester for graduates under two dollars
a semester it creates an annual budget
of a hundred and forty thousand enough
to bring back positions keep printing
papers and keep business going as usual
I didn't know there was newspaper and I
wouldn't really be using it so why would
I pay for it I mean they put unnecessary
fees all the time this one at this fee
is actually necessary so three dollars
wouldn't hurt me when considering like
all factors and honestly our situation
this is the most feasible thing for us
to ensure the sustainability
indefinitely as a student newspaper
that meeting at UNLV scheduled to start
at noon this Friday it is open to the
public